the following table contains the first
five terms of given pattern a
generate pattern b according to this
rule for every term of pattern a so they
give us the terms of pattern a here
multiply the term by three and add 1 to
get the corresponding term of pattern b
then graph the pairs of corresponding
terms
so every for every term in pattern a we
want to multiply by 3 and add 1. so if
we multiply 0 by 3 we get 0 and you add
one you get one
you multiply one by three you get three
and then you add one you get four
two times three is six
plus one is seven
three times 3 is 9 plus 1 is 10.
remember we're just multiplying by 3 and
adding 1. 4 times 3 is 12 plus 1 is 13.
so those are the corresponding terms for
pattern b and then they ask us to graph
them so let's try to graph these points
let's try to graph these points so when
pattern a is zero
pattern b is one when pattern a is zero
so this is pattern a equaling zero
that's our horizontal axis the value of
pattern a
pattern b is the value of our vertical
axis pattern b is one
when pattern a is one pattern b is four
so it's one
four so when pattern a is one pattern b
is four pattern b is on the vertical
axis
when pattern a is two pattern b is seven
so two
and seven
when pattern
a is 3 pattern b is 10. so 3
10. so 3 in the horizontal direction
that's our pattern a value and our
pattern b value is 10
and then finally when pattern a is 4
when pattern a is 4 pattern b is 13.
pattern b is 13. now let's just look at
these patterns we see pattern a is
increasing by 1 each time
while pattern b
is increasing by its well pattern a
starts at zero and increases by one
while pattern b starts at one and
increases and increases by three which
makes complete sense it makes sense it
starts at one because all of these you
multiply by three and add one so you
start at 1 and then the fact that we're
multiplying by 3 that's what's leading
to the distance between these points
being 3.
so let's check our answer make sure we
got this we got this right and we did